bonsoir céline leriche merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france variant un
delta qui nous causent bien inquiétudes
qui représente maintenant plus de 51 %
des nouveaux cas au portugal plus de 70%
de la région de lisbonne
sa propagation est inéluctable comment
vous vous l'expliquer en tant que
médecin oui bonsoir il s'avère que le
portugal se retrouve avec un gros
dilemme c'est que on se retrouve avec
1604 contamination par jour depuis
presque une semaine dont plus de 1200 à
lisbonne dont 70% des contaminations
alors que les lisbonne et son aire
métropolitaine ne représentent que 27 %
de la population totale du portugal
c'est une ville on avait commencé le
plan de déconfinement à partir de mi
mars avec la réouverture des écoles qui
ont été fermées pendant deux mois et on
procéder par étape en ouvrant les
terrasses les restaurants etc
est on arrivé à un stade où la quatrième
phase de déconfinement du coup n'a pas
pu être envisageable à lisbonne
puisqu'on est passé au dessus du taux
d'incidence qui est de plus de 240
personnes pour cent mille habitants
alors vous vous travaillez oui vous
travaillez dans une clinique privée à
lisbonne expliquez nous comment ça se
passe les symptômes à ce qu'ils sont
différents avec ce variant delpastre
cela nous inquiète plus on voit en tout
cas moins d'hospitalisations moins
d'hospitalisations en réanimation et
donc ça c'est plutôt rassurant
est-ce que c'est dû aux variants delta
qui serait plus contagieux certes mais
peut-être pas forcément avec une
mortalité plus forte
ou est-ce que tout simplement les gens
fragiles à risque d'hospitalisation ou
d'être admis en réanimation sont
vaccinés il faut pas oublier que le
portugal réussi à vacciner
42 % de sa population avec une dose et
27% de la population totale du portugal
a reçu les deux doses
donc je ne peux pas dire si le variant
delta permet et moins à une mortalité -
ou si c'est tout simplement parce que la
population a été vaccinée
vous voyez beaucoup de patients qui ont
été vaccinés et qui ont contracté ce
delta beaucoup non mais quelques-uns et
ils sont dans quel état en général ce
sont des santons sans gravité quand ils
ont été vaccinées alors ce que j'ai vu
comme je suis dans une clinique qui n'a
pas de réanimation et soins continus non
c'est forcément des gens qui ne sont non
pas des symptômes graves parce que
ceux-là sont directement dirigés à
l'hôpital mais clairement le nom de mor
journalier et le nombre
d'hospitalisations en réanimation est
très faible
les nouvelles restrictions on rappelle
les horaires et la capacité donc
d'accueil et des restaurants et des
commerces ont de nouveau été réduite est
ce que c'est c'est suffisant pour vous
pardon excusez moi j'ai pas entendu les
nouvelles restrictions qui ont été mises
en place au portugal est ce qu'elles
sont suffisantes pour vous elles sont
quand même pas mal c'est à dire que les
restaurants et commerces doivent fermer
à 15h30 les samedis et dimanches et les
samedis et dimanches donc week-end à
partir du vendredi 15 heures jusqu'au
lundi matin 6 heures on n'a pas le droit
de circuler en dehors de l'airé
métropolitaine de lisbonne il ya en ce
moment l'euro de foot qui se joue on en
a parlé il ya quelques instants avec
cette nouvelle a notamment d'ailleurs
300 supporters qui sont revenus de
moscou testés positifs au co vide
est-ce que clairement cette compétition
et le fait qu'on fasse des matchs avec
va des milliers de personnes dans des
salles c'est de nature à relancer une
épidémie oui et non parce que au niveau
par exemple il n'ya pas de fan zones où
il n'ya pas les bars ferment à 22h30 la
semaine 15h30 le week-end donc autant
dire qu'on peut pas voir il n'y a pas de
match diffusé à l'extérieur
après c'est sûr que les tests
antigénique au pcr de 72 ou 48 heures
laisse quand même passé des gens qui
sont potentiellement positif il n'y a
pas que l'euro il ya eu la finale de la
champion's league entre deux clubs
anglais qui a eu lieu le 29 mai à porte
ou conclusion l'europe pas assez
vacciner selon vous je dirais que la
vaccination permet je pense malgré tout
vu le nombre de contaminations quotidien
d'avoir moins d'hospitalisations et
moins d'admissions en réanimation mais
probablement qu'elle suffira pas à
enrayer les contaminations on voit bien
dans divers pays qui ont été vaccinés ou
presque la moitié la population se
retrouve avec des pcr positive et comme
c'est une solution mais c'est peut-être
pas le miracle
merci céline le riche médecin
généraliste france exerçant lisbonne
d'avoir été avec nous avoir exposé la
situation au portugal avec désormais
donc la domination de ce variant delta